welcome everyone to the live signing of
johnny the walrus with the one and only
matt walsh hello and good evening to you
all we welcome our friends be they big
or small human or even aquatic mammal
okay that was a terrible rhyme but to be
fair i am not a best-selling children's
author however i do happen to know
someone who is he is the cardigan
wearing author of the number one
best-selling book johnny the walrus and
host of the matt walsh show on the daily
wire ladies and gentlemen the one and
only matt walsh
i can't believe they made you do that
first of all but so thank you for thanks
for being involved in this and this is
like
it feels like i'm in dr seuss's fever
dream or something this is very strange
but it's also it's a it's a huge uh
honor as well yeah well matt is live
tonight against the wishes of amazon
employees it seems working on signing
all the copies of the books everyone has
been ordering and as matt's here for the
next hour or so signing and unable to go
anywhere we will be hanging out doing
his favorite thing chit chatting and
asking him questions
so submit your questions in the chat box
on dailywire.com
any daily wire member can chime in now
if you want to get your hands oh my gosh
oh what's happening
a great start
if you want to get your hands
on one of these limited edition
autographed johnny the walrus books
there is only one way to get one and
that is with a daily wire all access
membership sign up right now at
dailywire.com
johnny and you will get an autographed
book plus your very own leftist tears
tumbler
which will come in handy since there are
lots of leftist tears flowing right now
many of which were caused by our man of
the hour
all righty here we go i'm gonna you
already have one to get started so then
i just start signing the books i guess
that's the idea okay
uh
this is actually embarrassing because i
have a i have a i have the
handwriting of a
like an actual four-year-old so this is
a guy when it's right that's gonna see
it i'm gonna try to close up okay
now matt this book has been causing
quite a stir recently it's been number
one on amazon for four days now four
days uh it was number one for five days
actually okay and uh now it's it's
it's gone down the charts a little bit
but still i think in the top ten we'll
call it nice and um
it was it is still by rights the number
one children's book in america yes uh
but it was kicked off the children's
book
uh
category by amazon buy the trigger at
amazon right employees
which is
you know one of my one of my great
dreams in life was obviously to to be a
children's book author which uh we've
been able to achieve and i feel great
about that
look at that okay um
so i feel great about that but
and then my other great dream is to
traumatize you know employees of big
tech companies so obviously we've been
able to achieve both of my dreams i can
basically
i need to retire now and
call it a day we've done both those
videos the leaked videos of the amazon
employees that was fantastic was that a
was that a man or a woman on the right
side
yeah i i
i have no idea it was quite
uncomfortable honestly it was
peak comedy and they've never seen
anybody more triggered by like just such
a sweet you know children's book author
yeah that's that's the thing you know
one of my disappointments is that
i wrote this children's book and i
thought that now that i'm wearing the
cardigan and i'm a children's book
author
that it would kind of soften my image
and people would like me more
and what i've discovered is that people
are actually
angry which which i never expected i
thought that this would that this book
would just this was your rebranding i
thought this would be critically
acclaimed that's what i thought so well
you know that's been at this point but
other than that it's been it's been a
great experience and you know the other
thing about the amazon thing i want to
say is that um
you know if you saw those videos
they
featured in their little uh cry session
uh a
a complaint from a customer and they
said the amazon
right
and and the amazon employee said that oh
well this person summarizes the book
really well and then the woman comes on
and claims that my book
commands children to go out
and murder i saw that people yes
that is that's a sort of a gritty dark
reimagining of the johnny the walrus
story well that's like if it was turned
into like a horror film yeah well that's
you know that's if like christopher
nolan did the
did the gritty reboot of johnny the
walrus but that's not what i have my
book doesn't tell you to kill anybody no
obviously um now matt we have our first
question
this is from johnny um hi matt johnny
the walrus here uh do you plan on
writing any more children's books in the
future
uh well certainly of course i do i mean
i am a i am a capitalist pig after all
so of course i'm going to keep writing
them and but you know at the same time
also there's
obviously what we've discovered from
this book is that there is a real hunger
out there
in the marketplace for books that are
for children's books that are not woke
because i know as a look at my look at
my signature do we say look how terrible
that is it's not even though yeah i
don't know if you can see that
this is what you're getting
anyway
um no there is if you look at the amazon
reviews of the book there's a lot of
people that are saying like oh like i'm
a grandparent this is so exciting like
i've been looking for things and the
library is just full there was this um
lives of tick tock posted a video and it
was a librarian
who was there were two librarians one
was uh putting banned books back in the
new york public library and handing them
out for free and then there was the
gal or they them i don't know she kind
of looks like a furry to be quite honest
my friends um was saying that she was
putting little like pride flags on all
the books and that kind of thing to show
which one was like lgbt and all that
so there is a need we know as as that's
the thing as parents we know that
there's really nowhere you can go in the
culture anymore except to uh daily wire
if you come daily where i remember where
you're not where you're not gonna be
exposed to this kind of woke stuff and
it's
even in libraries especially in
libraries i mean libraries
for the last several years that's where
you can go for the
drag queen story hours and all that kind
of stuff um
and i knew from experience as a parent
you go to the bookstore go to you know
any major bookstore go to the children's
section and it just it looks like uh you
know the signs at an antifa rally or
something with all the
all of the anti-racist gender ideology
and stuff people are tired of that so
i mean this book was
the number one book in the entire
country
of all books that were sold for a week
okay clearly a a board book
for preschoolers that satirizes gender
ideologies the number one book in the
entire country well it's quite brilliant
uh we have another question for you this
is from lillian she's saying out of all
of the prestigious titles you've won
between your release of johnny the
walrus and what is a woman which one is
your favorite
uh i mean there are so many they even go
before that i've you know of course
became a philanthropist with um our
charitable endeavors for aoc's abuela
yes um and that
as a philanthropist that is a title that
is very important to me
uh theocratic fascist is another title
that i find very important
but um
especially with what is a woman i would
say now that
my what is woman book is charting still
as the number one
biology text on amazon fantastic um i
would say that i really appreciate being
a
biologist and that means that i'm a
scientist trust the science folks yep
your science trademark like that
yourself science all right now um ashley
phillips is saying
i just found a catholic group that
describes themselves as pro-life
democrats they believe the democrats are
right on most things but wrong on
abortion thoughts
um
a pro-life democrat was was what she
said right yeah catholic pro-life sorry
they told me i have to sign this and
answer questions but i'm too stupid to
do things a few things at once you're
doing great uh yeah it's not possible to
be a pro-life democrat i mean the
democrat party down to its very core is
um
it's not just abortion i mean their
entire platform
is structured around their
hatred for human life and the dignity of
life so that's just an incompatible
position i think you just you have to
choose you're either pro-life or
democrat and
be pro-life
straight from the uh number one
biologist and children's book author in
the world uh let's see conservative gal
asked hi matt do fans ever approach you
and your family in public if so how do
you react i know you prefer to never
talk and never have to make small talk
they do and i scream at them and i throw
whatever is closest at hand at them no
i'm just kidding i uh they do and you
know i appreciate it as long as they're
nice and that's the thing everybody
look at this what is that that's not a
signature that's just
that's chinese or something i don't know
what that is um
i do appreciate people and the thing is
of all the of all the angry messages i
get and hate mail and death threats and
all that kind of stuff nobody
has ever actually come up to me in
public except on a college campus when
there's a whole group of them yeah
nobody's ever come to me individually in
public and
who hates me and confronted me
person-to-person because most people are
just yep
well you've been doing this a lot longer
than i have but all of my interactions
thus far have been the same it's all
very very positive and it's people are
usually nice but i do
i'm waiting for the day that somebody
hates me
on a few cases i've had somebody
message me and say hey i just saw you at
some place and i want you to let you
know that you're a terrible person like
oh tough guy
well if you haven't seen
matt in public you can become a daily
wire all access member and you can go
over you can subscribe and if you are an
all access member you can have the
opportunity to ask him questions just
like this when he does all access lives
it's the only way to have access to us
hosts if you are not running into us at
farmer's markets or something like that
and if you want matt to answer any of
your questions tonight be sure to go
over to our live stream at dailywire.com
click the live banner at the top of the
page and you can
flood him with your questions what do
you think about that i'm doing a thing
here with the signature where the m
turns into the w
that's artistic are you gonna start
doing art now well i i just decided just
now on the spot to make that my new
signature so this is that's exciting
this is actually just a creative project
for you
you just saw the origin story of my new
signature live on the air
all right let's see uh how can i be more
like matt walsh this question is uh
let's see the greatest man to ever walk
the earth and grace us with such
wonderful works of literature
um
i had to throw at least one in there
that i wrote myself and that obviously
is the one
uh
don't
set higher goals for yourself than to be
like me there's just you know
you gotta you gotta aim higher than like
look at your setup true you have here
true are you kidding me true it's
impressive uh let's see this is uh from
very stable genius is the username
my daughters want to know how johnny's
whiskers go away i told them he stopped
eating worms can i get sweet daddy
walsh's confirmation from this or on
this um
yes and that is a debate
you know within the johnny the walrus
extended universe there's a lot of
debate about kind of the mythology of
giant ballers and
yeah because he goes to the doctor and
he gets the uh the
hormone pills
uh because we're being very subtle with
our
allegory here and then but he stops
taking the pills and then he uh
kind of goes back although if the
allegory was completely correct then
he'd stopped taking the pills and
he would not go back to normal because
irreversible damage right exactly
all right now brandon is asking out of
all of the animals there are why did you
choose a walrus as the metaphor we're
getting deeper and
that question was almost certainly
submitted by my wife because she
wants to make sure that i make very
clear that it was actually her idea the
walrus thing was her idea um this was a
collaborative effort a lot of ways so my
wife
she
the genesis of johnny deliver says my
wife suggested to me
like a year ago that i should write a
children's book
and um
and she said you know because she
pointed out that if i wrote a children's
book it'd make a lot of people very
upset just by the simple fact that i
wrote it and i said well i love that
idea and so we went back and forth about
the idea
and um i kind of had the general concept
of johnny the walrus and i said to her
but i need an animal that the kid
pretends to be and i need a name and
just right there on the spot she says
johnny the walrus it was just a moment
of
it was collaborative genius it was a
moment where we both knew that that was
it's the perfect marriage honestly
all right now we have six new members
that have joined while we've been doing
this live this is impressive uh let's
say hello to jacqueline from magnum am i
saying that manga oklahoma dory from
bozeman montana and richard from port
allen louisiana
and matt do you have anything you want
to say to them
uh
no oh wait i do
i just want to take a moment to say
thank you my sweet sweet babies and that
you're special
i'm so happy to have you as members of
my
cult
your soul is mine
i wore a sweet baby gang shirt the other
day in a video and i had a lot of your
cult members come in and they were like
oh my gosh it's a crossover
it's very intense the cult is growing um
lightning speed i was i told a story on
my show
yesterday i was at my my kids first
communion
over the weekend and somebody shouted
the sweet baby gang at my kid's first
communion so
i thought it was great my wife
was a little bit more iffy on the whole
thing but um really making waves
yeah that's uh and i look i here's my
thing in the sweet big game i don't
think that there is an inappropriate
time
to shout out sweet baby you know
i could be at a funeral and i think
that's perfectly appropriate well it's a
very
malleable phrase you can use it anywhere
now amanda the real deal says dear sweet
daddy will you be collaborating with the
director of tusk for the live action
movie adaptation of johnny the walrus
um
first of all i found out about tusk
after i wrote this book and everyone
said oh you were inspired by tusk and i
said what are you talking about
and i looked up what this movie is and
it's like okay then i was horribly
disturbed because i saw the images on i
would i would not recommend looking up
apparently if you actually try to
literally become a walrus it's um
it gets pretty grim pretty fast so who
is the director of that do we know no i
don't know somebody here now kevin smith
is the director
so no because he's like a far left
lunatic maybe i'll start saying i wasn't
i'm gonna start saying i was inspired by
tusk just because it would probably
annoy him she started tweeting at him
yeah
you can say why aren't we gonna
collaborate i'm sure that would trigger
him kevin smith thank you so much for
inspiring this book i could have done it
without you you're gonna give him
nightmares okay now kelly says hey matt
just wondering are there going to be
differences in the book and the
documentary of what is a woman are there
going to be differences or more in-depth
discussions and one or the other sweet
baby gang for life
um
i i think there yeah there are
differences you get you get a certainly
different experience from both
um
i can't
there's still so much to be said about
the about the film in particular that i
still can't say but i'll have much more
to say about it soon
um
but
i will say there are aspects of the
story that
we can't really get into depth on until
we get to the book but then there are
also aspects that you can't fully
appreciate there are a lot of aspects of
the story that you can't fully
appreciate unless you see the movie and
you see the visuals there are a lot of
visuals here that you just have to see
some of which you wish you had not seen
but
you're going to see them let's see well
everyone who is watching you can get
yourself one of matt's autographed
johnny the walrus books and a leftist
tears tumbler by becoming a daily wire
all access member sign up for a daily
wire all-access membership at
dailywire.com
johnny and if you are already an
all-access member one thank you and two
you also have exclusive access to get a
signed copy of johnny the walrus just
head over to the daily wire store at
dailywire.com and click shop at the top
of the page again all access members are
the only ones who can get the signed
limited edition copy of johnny the
walrus so if you are already a member
head on over
and uh place your order now because
these are
you're flying through these like
hotcakes i mean look at that signature
you want one of these
look at that wow you know what i'm going
to do that's good i'm going to add a
little smiley face to that one oh that
i've never done that before
that's another first that one's going to
be
it'll never happen again we won't speak
of it okay alrighty now we have a nice
message from someone here
hey matt as a world renowned children's
author biologist and the four most
theocratic fascists in american history
when are you throwing your hat in the
race 2024
um
i would
rather be
set on fire and then drowned um
that's what i always say instead of
running for office like i'd rather i'd
literally rather be dead than run for
office so
uh that will just simply never happen at
all ever yep
and how dare you even ask me
you're banned from this book signing get
out
you've been from the sweet baby gang
yeah yeah
alrighty steven has a question
why do we not see or hear about johnny's
dad in the book i assume it is because
johnny's dad was at work to provide for
his family thanks matt um no not at all
it's not the reason in fact there was a
it was a there's a very pointed it's a
very it's a very pointed absence not
having johnny walrus's dad in the
picture because
you're gonna find so often with kids who
um
are
led into these delusions that the father
is either
physically not abs physically absent or
he might be physically present but he's
you know emotionally psychologically
spiritually absent so
um the fact that the father is an
absence in this tale
is quite intentional
and also the fact that
so much of the story really we call
johnny walrus but so much of the story
is really about the mom
because
you know again when you have a child
in this situation in real life
it's really the parents very often who
are leading the charge there
uh i was watching i saw a tick tock
earlier of this woman who is
yelling about her child's pediatric or
pediatrician it was her nine-year-old
and the pediatrician said the
nine-year-old is not old enough to know
herself and know that she wants to
transition so no i'm not gonna
prescribe her any hormone therapy or
even sign letter to get her like her
name changed and the mother was
basically like having a meltdown saying
like my child wants this it was just
yeah you see that and it's like these
mental delusions it's criminal i saw
that clip and that's that's that mother
managed to find and she was upset about
finding but she managed to find one of
the only good pediatricians left in
america shocking she was upset about it
um but that's of course exactly what
every any doctor should say because kids
you know my oldest kids are uh eight
years old almost nine
and um even at that age they just have
no clue about the world about themselves
they can't make any decisions
at all so the idea that they could be
able to choose their own gender is
totally ridiculous yep
um like an example i give all the time
just a simple example is
you know if you take your
kid to the restaurant
and the waiter comes out
and then you say to your kid this and i
feel always feel bad for waiters when
parents do this because the way you're
standing there and then you say to the
kid well what would you like to have
and then they're going to sit there for
45 minutes going through everything on
the menu before they settle on something
and then you get that for them and then
you bring it out and they don't want to
eat it because they actually wanted
something else so it's just kids can't
decide anything they can't make any
choices
well at nine years old i said this on my
show earlier i think i was running
around wearing harry potter cloaks and i
thought that i was a wizard
i am one i had nine or eight nine oh no
this was last week actually you know i
was out in franklin and i was
you know running around casting spells
uh no
um all right we have a this is not a
question this is just a nice message
from laura
she says hi matt i keep thinking i'm
going to send you an email about all the
things i agree with you on but you'd be
reading a 10 plus page email no one has
time for that i did want to tell you
though that today is my birthday i got
the best gift of all a copy of johnny
the walrus my husband bought me a copy
because i kept talking about it and he
surprised me with it this morning he
also bought me the cleaning supplies you
talked about for valentine's day thank
you they work really well and i use them
all the time thanks so much for your
podcast it's awesome and i really enjoy
listening to it every day it was really
nice well ma'am you are married to a
great man that's all i could say and um
i don't usually do this because i'm
against birthdays but i will i'll make
an exception
because i'm in the
children's author uniform and i'm
feeling more generous and i will say
happy birthday man i thought you're
about to sing and i was going to be
really into no no that's not good it's
going to be like this is an odd
character development here
i've been told that my singing voice
sounds a little bit like a dying moose
and um
i've never heard a moose die but i
assume that's not a compliment so that
could be your next children's book
the moose
the dying moose
a little bit of a darker direction well
they're already saying you have a dark
children's book you just lean into it
uh let's see andrea says how long did it
take you to write johnny the walrus what
was the writing process like
um
it
took many many
many
seconds
of effort to write a variable it's a
very thick book i mean yeah it's you
know look at look at the thickness of
that book of course there's only like
two words per page but still
let's see okay
we have uh this is another question from
nra certified lover boy
i'm sorry what now
who's it from
his username is nra certified loverboy
nra certified loverboy so that
that username takes all kinds of weird
turns i kinda like it ends with me being
confused i like the chaos well it's good
you're using that walsh all right if you
had to come up with an alias like dr
seuss what would it be that's a good one
um
well i wouldn't because i
want all the credit for the book that i
wrote i don't know why people would do
that i thought uh
you know mark twain doctors i mean i
want the credit personally so why would
i ever do something like that
okay all right so we have oh we have
three new members uh this is from that
group earlier so we have victoria from
grand prairie texas
uh christopher from uh westerfield ohio
and christian from michigan
love it
those are the same ones no these are new
ones okay so if you wanna you wanna
welcome them to the sweet baby gang into
the daily wire all access world we're
doing this okay well look
if i could say one thing to you
and one thing only
i would say
you're one of a kind
and i'm so happy and i'm so proud of you
and i'm so glad that you're all a part
of my sweet baby gang
i kind of like i feel like that should
be like a
and a ringtone or something like people
can call into that people do ringtones
anymore because if they had a ring not a
wrinkle but a voicemail like if we set
up like a hotline where people could
call and just hear that message
from the soothing voice of a
number one best-selling children's
author
let's uh let's just move on with our
lives and pretend
none of this is happening
all right uh
this one is from kent pittsburgh he says
are you planning a johnny trilogy and
creating a johnny universe and a johnny
multiverse this guy has big dreams for
you um
yeah well that's kind of the big
question right now in the creative
development department where we're
sitting down sitting with the creative
team for hours a day we're talking about
this and um so you and your wife yeah
exactly
and so the question is do you you know
do you do you continue the story of
johnny or has this the johnny story been
told is there more to say about johnny
um or do you extend it into the johnny
the walrus universe but you let
johnny be you know as with this happy
happily ever after sort of ending
and i don't know we're still we're still
working that out
big dreams it's an intense creative
process
um are you like johnny the walrus like
do you have a big uh imagination and
lots of questions um i didn't even
realize that this was i thought i was
asking you a question um what are you
like are you like who's asking this
question you're asking yourself i'm
about to ask you but i wanted to ask you
i was gonna ask them but i wanted to ask
you are you
do you find yourself like johnny uh yeah
this was basically an autobiography of
this book
but you wanted this is a true story but
isn't the illustration
my parents tried to abandon me at a zoo
that's actually that's actually is that
that's the only true part um and uh well
i think that this is you right
that's me in this yeah so that's that's
how we've kind of done it i'm just
kidding by the way my parents did not
abandon me at a zoo
my mom is watching this so i'm gonna get
us all later
alrighty now if you are uh like johnny
and you have a big imagination and lots
of questions for matt we want to hear
them so type your questions into the
daily wire chat box at dailywire.com and
we will hit matt with them he is still
sitting here he is not allowed to leave
he has to continue chit chatting with me
brianna has a question for you how much
longer is it
okay
matt loves me he loves hanging out with
me all the time um hi matt my husband
and i are pregnant with our first baby
we are starting prep work and thinking
about homeschooling i know you are a big
advocate but we really don't know how it
works and would love to know what you
and your wife do to homeschool your
children
um
you know
the thing that i do for homeschooling is
um just that i
my wife does it and i i'm really like
moral support
so i'm there to say hey had a girl doing
a great job uh no i mean she does do
most of the homeschooling because i'm
because i'm at work most of the day so
but it's what i'll say is that
homeschooling is a
it's a
i i think that sometimes people in
homeschooling community can uh under
emphasize the difficulties of it like it
is it is really hard to do
but if that's just the case with
parenting in general i mean parenting is
a difficult thing but it's incredibly
rewarding and i think that uh
once
you'll hear from most homeschooling
parents that uh once they started kind
of homeschooling they realize that
although it's hard it's not as hard as
they thought it would be and it's also
really rewarding and you know it's
actually nice to have your kids around
for for the day um
if you can believe it you might actually
start enjoying your kid's company
you know i was home schooled for my
entire life
and look how you turned out here you go
i know did you turn out well or what i
think i did i'm sitting here with you
true good point look so this is the
dream um but no that's true about people
underestimate underestimating how hard
it is i think a lot of people also
forget that
that's where kind of like the stigma
about like the social interactions and
that kind of thing but you are taking on
their social development as well as
academic which is a whole
other uh ball game well what you're
doing is you're taking on the job of
being a parent first time
rather than pawning it off to the school
system
uh which you know it is it is easier in
the in the short term to pawn that off
to the school system but
i don't think it works best for your
kids especially these days
all right now lindsay is asking
how did you propose to your wife how
long did it take for you to know that
you wanted to marry her this is a sweet
one
um i knew that i wanted to marry her i
mean honestly was i would say like about
six
minutes probably um
maybe a little bit longer than that but
i proposed after six months
and
i think kind of like one it people have
this idea these days that first of all
i'm so hot in this sweater i don't know
if it's obvious look at me how much i'm
sweating it's disgusting feeling it
people think these days that
you know you have to be with someone for
like
five years before you know if they're
marriage material but i think once you
realize that
you have
the deepest things in common you have
the same basic values and priorities in
life you want the same thing out of life
you're both taking the relationship
seriously
and all of that then
i think it's you know you know you can
move on to the next stage which is
engagement and how did you propose to
her
i did it's pretty cliche but i did
propose on a beach so
that was my romantic
that was my one attempt
all righty now we have another question
um they say we love the book question i
skipped the word bigot because i don't
want my three-year-old running around
saying big it all the time thoughts did
you have hesitance before putting that
uh in the book p.s my son loves the book
and so do we
yeah i mean we don't want to put
anything we didn't want to put any words
or concepts in the book that we wouldn't
want
a kid to be
introduced to which is why
in spite of what amazon
the amazonians claim it actually does
not say the word transgender in the book
at all um
but you know i think it's it's just a
judgment call i mean a word like big
it's not it's not a curse word it's a
word that unfortunately people encounter
that you're even your kids are going to
encounter pretty young ages
and um
i actually think it's a good thing for
kids to they hear the word bigots you
know and to them
they hear it first in this book and so
to them it's so they see it in this sort
of like silly context it's a silly word
doesn't mean anything and that's the
truth because that's that's actually the
way the word bigot is used these days as
emotional blackmail uh it basically
doesn't mean anything anymore so
i think it's not a bad thing for them to
have that kind of framework for the word
let's see
uh let's see oh we have another question
what is your favorite children's book
besides johnny the walrus of course
um i am a dr seuss
guy from way back in the day even before
he was canceled you know i liked dr
seuss before it was cool so
i'm a big cat in the hat you know fox
and socks is my jam
hop on pop even though it promotes
elder abuse arguably
all those books did you ever uh
read the giving tree
um
i kind of always hated that book that
was probably the children's book that i
despised the most i did read it and i
found it to be incredibly weird and sad
and disturbing yeah kind of like johnny
delivers just kidding there you go no
it's not
uh i think that was the one that my mom
didn't even let me
like keep in the house after a while
just because i think it disturbed her as
well all right we have another question
would there be a johnny the walrus
animated show on daily wire kids that's
a good question
um
i would love it but you got to talk to
uh you got to talk to the god king
you're going to i mean that's this is
not my call so put the pressure on him
to make it tweeting at jeremy yeah
so if you are just joining us we are
here live with best-selling lgbt
children's author matt walsh as he
autographs copies of his number one book
johnny walrus which is only available to
daily wire all access members so if you
are not already a member and you want to
be one
go to dailywire.com
johnny and you will get a signed johnny
the walrus book plus a leftist tears
tumbler for free when you join it's a
great deal you are missing out if you
are not an all access member
let's see
this is getting a card i feel like i
need to like sit on the floor and hand
me these now yeah i'm obviously working
up a sweat by signing these books and
also by having i said before we went on
the air that's like really hot in here
and i'm dressed for 40 degree
temperatures and then
oh my gosh this is just well i feel like
as like a
children's author you're kind of having
that whole character i feel like like
men you know i i see i see like an old
children's like author and he's like a
sweet little old man who always kind of
like runs cold and has a chill
so you see an old sweaty man when you're
looking at me but i wouldn't think
you need to be pretending like you have
a chill like you're just always kind of
oh i don't have a chill at all i'm like
dying at the exhaustion right now okay
we're gonna distract you from that uh
because justin has a question for you uh
what do you think the most important
subjects are that should be
taught to students in k-12
um
hydration is really important so don't
pass out
when you're wearing a cardigan
when it's 80 degrees inside of here oh
yeah i do have water don't i good point
um
most important subjects in school
uh i think the subjects that they
allegedly actually teach the core
subjects are all really important uh the
problem is you actually have to teach
them like teach oh there's no look at
that you know what i know it distracts
from the audio a little bit but then
visually you're saved from what you're
seeing right now which is the good part
by having the air on
so teach
teach history you know i think that's
one of the most important and most
neglected subjects in school right now
um
kids have no understanding of their own
history you know where they
where they
where their country came from or
anything like that so i think that's
probably the most important subject that
was a good one you did a little twist in
there
look at this
look at that
that was pretty good yeah i like that
uh let's see we have what advice do you
have for my wife who is a preschool
teacher and terrified of reading this
book in her class
i would say
just do it and deal with the
consequences when it comes that's my
that's my thing i think uh look
that
in every school in america they've got
the opposite of this book and so there's
no reason like you have a pretty good
argument if you read the book and you
get in trouble and the administration is
coming after you um you have a pretty
rock solid argument
and also what it really is the book it's
actually a book but i'm trying to tell
people what i've been saying is it's
actually a book about self-acceptance
it's about teaching kids to accept
who they actually are who they really
are authentically um
and when i was a kid
every book
the core message of every children's
book was self-acceptance
and uh you know way back in the dark
days of the 90s
and that's what this book is like accept
who you really are
don't try to reach for some delusional
version of yourself
i think that uh brings us to our
next question this person has a deep
question uh what is a walrus
a walrus is an adult human oh no that's
the other one um
the definition of well you know a walrus
is really
a walrus is anyone who identifies as a
walrus
anyone who identifies as a walrus as a
walrus
what would walrus pronouns be well while
we have that in the book actually i
think
i think it's that's somewhere in there
that's an easter egg you can find it
wall rocks is one of those they want to
be it's on one of the posters yeah we do
have the official walrus pronouns in
here i'm missing it he him wallrucks
while rucks yeah those are the pronouns
i should put that in my bio walrus
maybe i'll become one
uh oh we have new members morning
members thank you all for signing up
during this it means we're doing a good
job i think
uh let's see luke from san diego uh
crystal from washington and melissa from
new river arizona
are you gonna welcome them oh
you know
in these stressful times
the best thing you could do is take a
breath
and listen
specifically listen to me and rest
assured once you open your heart and
your ears to me you will find answers
what the hell am i reading who wrote
what
i get because i'm a cult leader is that
what that's supposed to be well it's for
your podcast you know all right
they listen to you every morning and
they become enlightened
uh yeah i guess it is you know i do
advertise myself as a cult leader so i
got to start leaning into that
you know where the robes too
um
that's the next stage got it moving on
from cardio this is too hot you got to
move into something a little more that
would certainly be a lot
more appropriate for the temperature
let's see okay we have another one uh
what would you rather be forced to do
use a microwave or leave your shopping
cart in the middle of a parking lot
um
rather be forced to do well i mean i
would i would use the microwave i mean
for me the shopping cart issue is at the
core of my
moral
identity
my anti-microwave stance is not quite
that
deep seated so
i don't know just microwaves i think are
unnecessary you don't really need them
uh whatever your microwave does you have
other appliances in your kitchen that do
the same thing and probably do it better
how do you feel and it probably causes
cancer i have no information for that
whatsoever but i just assume that it
does how do you go about the microwave
that we have in the break room but it
does like multiple functions it's not
just a microwave which shocked me it's
weird i see i don't use it that's the
thing i think microwaves make the food
always taste worse that's the other
thing so
and that's that's the other point about
microwaves that's really important is
that
since this is what we're talking about
now
if you're
using a microwave
to heat up like leftovers you're almost
always better off just eating them cold
to begin with so which is how most
leftovers should be consumed
that's my stance on that that's a hot
take shoot a ted talk on that
it's true your next
book let's see uh
this one is from totally not an alien
have you been in touch with aliens if
not would you like to do you think the
government is cooperating with me i mean
them already um totally not an alien i i
have not i very much would like to be in
touch with aliens i
have made clear
to the aliens that you know i'm on their
side and i fully welcome them to
take over and slave us incinerators
whatever they feel like they need to do
although i did just read
and i i only read the headline like a
good americans because that's all i do
but i read the new york post article
that
nasa scientists are sending nude images
of
people into space
to try to entice aliens i'm not making
that up
that was a headline anyway
uh did you see
i don't know i don't know anything else
all i know is that they're sending nude
images we are sending unsolicited nudes
to
alien civilizations
we are sexually harassing
e.t i we're talking about this is you're
signing your children's book that's what
we're doing i didn't decide to do that
nasa's doing that this is why we need to
elon musk needs to buy nasa
because we're going to become
you know sex slaves of aliens or
something this is horrifying did you
watch demi lovato's show
where she
they
what alien self goes and sings oh yeah
so that she made contact with i actually
believe that i mean she
i believe that there's been some some
extraterrestrial
extraterrestrial influence over demi
lovato she did an interview i think it
was with uh drew barrymore or no
actually some like entertainment tonight
person and the entertainment tonight
person was like would you ever date
an e.t and she so confidently was like
yes i hate humans like i need to date
any tea
it might be the only people that uh
she can get along with at this point i
don't know demi lovato
i don't know if she was ever normal but
i feel like
her transition from normal to lunatic
has been quite dramatic and quite sudden
although i don't know maybe she's the
one uh putting together this
uh
little cooperation with nasa oh sending
the news
yeah it could be her that's a good
theory
let's see um as you can see yourself
matt is doing a masterful job i mean
look at wow that one was good you didn't
connect it there that kind of screwed
that okay well he was doing a masterful
job autographing these copies of johnny
the walrus and if you want one all you
got to do is become an all access member
so you can go to dailywire.com
johnny and one of these signed books
could be yours can you guys see right
there it says it's that's going to the
mailbox we are literally
we're finished these are going to go
straight in the mail
we'll have to repack this box a little
bit but uh
you're going to you're going to take
them to ups right after that i'm such a
mess yeah
right it's going to be great um
so if you are already an all access
member do not worry you also have
exclusive access to a signed copy of
johnny the walrus at
dailywire.com click shop at the top of
the page you can find this book get your
signed copy so if you're already a
member do not worry you are still
included
uh let's say all right nick baker has
another question
will the daily wire be producing an
official johnny the walrus halloween
costume that's fun
i hope so i will i will demand it now
that's the thing i have no idea about
what the daily wire is going to do
because i'm not in on any of those
conversations at all but uh
i will i'll push for that because i love
that idea that's good
um i'll be joining the walrus for
helping the entire office can be
yeah although
yeah
this whole thing's a fever this right
here is i mean it all is
let's see all right if everyone in the
daily wire turned into an animal which
animal do you think they would be and
why you're interested oh my gosh
all right what do you think i'll let you
answer that oh i'm gonna pawn that off
to you uh
would you be a walrus
um
that's a difficult question
i have no i have no opinion about what
animal i would be i've been a bird i
don't know i could fly i hate birds
you hate birds they scare me
i have like a genuine fear of birth i've
been attacked by siegel one too many
times
one too many times how many times have
you been attacked by like four i lived
in l.a
the heart that what happens in l.a they
do yeah i don't think you have to worry
about seagulls when you're walking down
not like in santa monica they're
terrifying and then we had a flock of
ducks when i was growing up because we
lived in a seagull euphemism for like
crackhead or something
okay well i'm also afraid of those but
then you can go to the beach and you
have seagulls
so i would not be a bird i've been told
before that i have the essence of like a
prairie dog or something like that or
you know like when you go to this when
you go to the zoo and it's like little
dogs that like pop out of the holes or
whatever yeah that would be a fairy dog
i don't know that's what i've been told
you want to be a small rodent who lives
in the dirt
well you can fly in there when you're a
bird that's the whole point you know
what
it's fine i would okay it could be any
animal animal kingdom but you'd be a
prairie dog i've just been told that i
wouldn't choose it for myself if you
come out of your hole you've been eaten
by an owl you're afraid of birds it
won't be a prairie dog i would be a well
i would be a koala i'm choosing that hey
what a koala oh okay so pick the most
useless animal on
the face of the earth listen everybody
likes koalas
only uh slightly less useless than the
panda but people know people know my
feelings about pandas yeah well i won't
be a panda we signed them all yeah we
did oh wow we have to keep chit chatting
though you're not allowed to leave yet
so we're gonna we're gonna actually go
through this all right so what so you
would be some kind of hold on a second
because i've already signed
all the books
and i'm feeling very generous so we got
these two things here am i still on
camera or am i just yeah i'm on camera
okay okay so my thought is
why don't i sign
johnny and the walrus
and then um
there we go
nice
and then uh i'll give
these two away to one of the one of our
new members one of our new all access
members well
we'll get this get this giant walrus
signed by me in the mail
and you can flip that on amazon sell it
for
ebay five dollars at least ebay yeah
how are you going to mail that
how are we going to mail it
that's uh
that's a problem someone else is going
to have to solve yeah handle it yeah
that's maybe that's it that's good i
will personally
bring this to your house
that part that's not weird at all at all
um i was going to make us continue the
animal question but i think that we got
down a bad rabbit hole
i don't know this is what we went down
it was very strange
listen the prairie doubles
okay i just don't understand okay we can
move on but you're afraid of birds and
so you're you want to be
i don't i don't want a of a bird
i don't want to be one i've just been
told before we're going to move on
because now i'm feeling
attacked i feel i'm triggered
just like the amazon now you know how
the amazon employees felt i know i'm
gonna tweet about this later
um how many cardigans do you have now
um i have uh i have a growing collection
but i have to keep them all
here
uh because my wife has promised to burn
them
if she ever gets a hold of them because
she does not like this whole children's
author she likes the children's author
thing but not the look she's not into
the look
which just makes me like it even more
because it annoys her and i find that
very funny so you should just buy a lot
of them you get a bundle
maybe we should start selling
matt walsh sweaters
make that a new merch item
i think i should sell them and not wear
them so that i'm not a
disguise it looks a little better see
once you put the air on it's not quite
so bad it's great all right since we
finished signing all of the books um we
just wanted to give you guys an update
we are here with matt walsh who is the
best-selling lgbt children's author and
the man the daily wire co-ceo and god
king lowercase g lowercase k jeremy
boring called a national treasure if you
have a question you'd like him to answer
join us on our live stream at
dailywire.com you can click the banner
at the top of the home page and type
your question into the daily wire chat
we already finished handing him all the
books he has signed all of them they are
in the box ready to be mailed to you
literally right after we finish this
stream so since we're finished with that
we're just going to answer your
questions so make sure that you submit
them asap so moving on
matt did you finally burn that horrid
polka dot shirt or is the dog sleeping
on it now
i can only assume that you ask that
because you want me to wear the shirt
again because you know that i only
started wearing the shirt because i wore
it once and then
um my own
audience made fun of me for it and so
then i started wearing it more just to
spite them because that's the level of
maturity that i have
and so now i feel like i got to start
wearing it again just because of that
comment i still have it
and i can pull it out anytime it's like
a threat so watch your mouth
all right this is from truthseeker
why should i buy johnny the walrus
um
because it would make me
very happy if you did
that's my whole pitch that's nice
and it's look it's it is literally
the literary sensation of 2022 so far
which might say a lot more about the
other books that have come out in 202
but um that's what it is so don't you
want to see what all the buzz is about
that's yeah that's the real reason like
why don't you have it already
uh all right so paul the walrus oh this
is good you're starting a whole thing
paula walrus says uh what is your alias
on the sweet baby gang facebook group
um
i do not have i am not part of this i've
been accused of this many times
apparently there is a sweet baby gang
facebook apparently multiple ones and um
that is
even though i'm the cult leader i
believe in giving the sweet babies a
little bit of privacy
you know to have their own conversations
as long as it's only nice things about
me of course
so i'm not on the group as far as you
know
it's disappointing to all of your fans
let's see uh were your kids a test
audience for johnny the walrus that's a
good one
they were and uh the honest truth is
that my kids actually love the book and
my two-year-old especially
loves this book and she has it basically
memorized and
she's constantly telling me about the
book she doesn't quite understand that i
wrote it but she does know that i'm like
she knows that i'm in it she doesn't
understand how daddy became the
zookeeper but um yeah she loves the book
so
and that's all that's all that matters
right it does uh let's see grace
elizabeth hannah she says just bought
the book for my mom who's a biologist as
well for mother's day any advice on how
we can get her to read it in her high
school science class
uh get
to
to read johnny the walrus in high school
science class
i mean i i just you got to present the
argument to her which is that um
this is
better scientific information than
[Music]
most high school science students are
getting so
you know in in a perfect world this
would not be appropriate for high school
students because it's for for
preschoolers but
we're not in this day and age yeah
basic uh preschool biology might be all
that high schoolers can handle all right
i mean i go to college campuses and i
give speeches um explaining
the basic anatomy of men and women on
college campuses and i get of course i
get protested for it so that's where
that's where we are right now so you
gotta you gotta start with the basics
with preschool level
understandable that's just too much
scientific depth for
anybody to really understand other than
you who's a world-renowned biologist all
right now shanna has a question from her
husband who claims that he is the
captain of sweet baby gang
he says i'm a troll husband much like
you mr walsh trolling my wife gives me
joy as it does to you
however my wife always responds by
saying i'm the girl you're not allowed
to troll me only i control you i have no
response to this she wins every time
what is your guidance oh sweet daddy
well who says that girl where did where
is this rule written in the book of life
that girls are not allowed to be trolled
this is
i believe
that trolling is one of the
deepest and most important things that
keeps a marriage together you know it's
uh
you don't really put it in your marriage
vows but
you have to i think it keeps your
marriage fresh when you're constantly
trying to annoy each other
i mean maybe don't take this marriage
advice to all the way to the bank but uh
that's that's at least the way that we
operate in my marriage
and we're we're happily married 11 years
now so it's worked out maybe you could
write a uh like a marriage advice book
next
yeah how to annoy the hell out of your
spouse be good
um let's see oh we have new members okay
um margaret from how do i pronounce this
bolivar
boulevard
boulevard
bolivar bolivar oh we're getting spicy
okay well margaret from bolivar ohio
sean from wisconsin and cody from
arkansas matt walsh has a special
message for you
i just want you to know
that i'm so proud of you
you may not have been the first new
member or the second or the third for
that matter
but you're here
you've made it
and for that
i couldn't be prouder of you
from the heart totally sincere i can't
give a straight face from this
let's see okay back to our questions
um this member is asking you are the
bands uh from the show for life can they
be appealed uh there's no appeal process
and they're totally for life and if you
come back they'll just be banned again
in perpetuity
until it sticks it's a good rule
consistency is key
uh nan uh nanny m says matt my 12 year
old boy is a huge fan and often asked to
listen to you i screen some of your
commentary and share it with him on
occasion he loves the fact that your
family also homeschools like we do he
said the other day how awesome it would
be to meet you someday and i told him
that the best thing to do
uh
i said the best thing to do then would
be to not talk to you that you'd prefer
to be ignored than put in the spotlight
so if we ever run into you what would
you like us to do so that i can be
prepared that's nice
um
you may
approach
eyes
down to the floor
and you can
have one
compliment which you say to me and then
you turn around and leave and that's
the process
actually i every single person comes up
to me the the first thing they do is
apologize for coming up to me
and um
so i'm starting to think do i give off
vibes as like
i think i'm a really approachable nice
guy but every person comes up i'm so
sorry i know you hate talking to people
sometimes i'm so sorry i know you hate
people but
i just
i think that's unfair i mean look at me
i'm in a cardigan
he's the sweetest man you've ever met
you're so approachable uh i should start
doing that with you when i see you in
the office i'm just going to keep my
eyes to the ground
move out of your way all right oh this
is cody are you i think cody was from
wisconsin maybe all right but he is
saying signed up for an all access and
purchased a second uh signed copy can i
get a shout out from my son who loves
you abel uh he said he loves you and
your book
shout out to abel
is that how you do a shout out right i
mean do you want to give him like a
message of affirmation
under your classic
you are so affirmed
so
that's good i'm proud of you
um all right
we have more new members kevin from
texas joseph from indiana and danielle
from california so now you need to
affirm them as well
you know
it's a beautiful day
at the daily wire
and i'm so glad you could join me today
on this beautiful day
this is getting it's getting laser as we
go on
um oh my goodness what is happening here
um i like you keep saying uh a beautiful
day as you're sweating profusely
oh all right here we go there you go
your water now hydration stay hydrated
oh we have more adam from tennessee carl
from california these are new members
yes so well you go ahead
i'm so glad
you're with us today
i just want to take a moment
to sort of take it all in
and
enjoy this time i have with you
couple second beat with closed eyes and
a smile open eyes and exhale oh i'm not
supposed to say that
wait what am i supposed to do scroll
down a little bit
closed eyes and a smile take a deep
breath
we need to enjoy their presence like a
moment this is getting this is too far
that's
you want to get the smile you can get
that closed eyes and smile i can't do
that that's a step too far anyway
thank you for enjoying this moment with
me
it's good okay
moving out of that wonderful peaceful
moment uh matt what is a woman and can
they become a walrus also shout out to
brett cooper because we have the same
name
love that amazing
all right there you go um a woman is an
adult human female that's what a woman
is
that's the whole
answer for for what is a woman
that has
very difficult for lots of people but
now
you know because sometimes when we talk
about this and even people who are the
sane and rational ones and uh they know
that these things are defined
biologically they'll they have some
people have a problem with that
definition because they say well a woman
you know a woman is isn't merely that
and true a woman's not merely that but
that is like the fundamental definition
of what a woman and then each indiv
woman individually of course has their
own identity and personality and
everything but um that is the
fundamental definition of of woman
simple and straight to the point
uh where did you buy your cardigan
somebody wants to know
um obviously from the clearance bin at
the
at goodwill
as you can
i'm a man of the people uh why did
johnny want to be a walrus and not a
panda i know you just went on your panda
ran a minute ago but
uh yeah i mean look walruses are they
are impressive animals at the end of the
day
you know and they they can fend for
themselves
they don't need
us to
sort of like keep them around um and
they're also it's like you know that
walruses
have been able to fend for themselves
and hold their own in the world because
they're such hideous animals that like
we would never
as as human beings like we're not trying
to keep them for pandas on the other
hand the only reason they still exist is
just that we think they're cute and so
we keep them around
walruses
these hideous beasts have to have had to
make their own path in life and i really
respect that
sure i had never thought about it that
way
since the red eye until this exact
moment wow improvisation right out of
that uh where would you put your sweet
baby gang tattoo
uh if i were to get one right across the
forehead that's what i would recommend
someone get it right across the forehead
that's good you should do that just when
your whole life is destroyed after you
do that don't blame me
uh will you cancel brett for making her
own cult the cooper troopers you try to
make your own call i don't i haven't
made a cold but on my most recent all
access life people were saying we're
going to be cooking
i knew this day would come that someone
else at daily wire tries to start a call
i knew it was going to happen
and if if that's what it comes down to
then fine we're going to go to war we
could do a crossover there's no
crossover yes cults don't do crossovers
cults cults are quite famously very
insular sorts of things you don't have
collaborations what if we had our cults
next to each other and they were like
tunnels
no it's gonna be like uh no this is it's
it's gang warfare at that point but it's
fine i i welcome the challenge let's i'm
very competitive
so you got some
time you have some um
you got to make up some time yeah
exactly i don't even have a facebook
group yet i need to work on that you're
already leagues ahead of me
uh let's see should i should i buy the
book for my nieces and nephews even
though their liberal parents will go
bonkers
even though
it's the more reason to that's that's
the whole reason to buy it right no it's
should i buy the book especially because
my the liberal parents will go boxes
yeah absolutely buy buy 10 of them leave
them like little uh
eggs around their house to find yeah
exactly hide them in different places
that's something people are doing by the
way um speaking of buying whole boxes of
them is that uh there are some people
that are buying them donating them to
libraries
um
a lot of especially in liberal
communities they have those not just
liberal communities but it's even better
in the liberal ones where they've got
those boxes on the street you know like
the
take a booklet book kind of community
library things
and people are buying the books putting
them in those so it's a great idea those
are yeah i like that so other than
triggering uh libs what are your hobbies
well
um
fishing is my
currently my my number one hobby i was
uh into beekeeping
you know which is why for a long time my
title was theocratic fascist and
beekeeper i'm getting back into the
beekeeping thing and now my next hobby
that i that i want to start for reasons
that i can't really explain my wife
keeps asking me to explain it but i
can't is um i want to get a big
expensive aquarium with lots of like
expensive fish
i don't know why but uh i'm just feeling
called to it i do feel called to it so
that was a good question that was
interesting i learned something about
you
uh would you ever do reptiles
like uh
too much
that's one of the reasons why i like the
fish ideas like reptiles require too
much upkeep i think
so i want to have an animal that can
just sort of be there when i want it to
be there okay so it's really all about
me got it well not not an animal that
requires like constant maintenance you
know okay i love it uh another member is
asking what is your favorite whiskey and
or tequila
uh favorite uh whiskey probably
you know i'm gonna go for a blanton's uh
bourbon
just um
your everyday sipper i like a four roses
a single barrel
good answer
alrighty
uh let's see all righty
okay no problem
oh love it we made it all right guys
what is happening right now okay we did
it we you successfully answered all the
questions without melting to death so
all right that looks like it will do it
for us tonight well done matt i'm very
proud of you for having to sit here and
sign all those books that was very
complicated for you
uh it is about that time all of the
books are signed and i am out of rhymes
do you like that
they made you go back to that well again
i thought it was really good i didn't
have to do as many of those as your
little uh affirmation moments but i
think it did pretty well so thank you
everyone for tuning in for our live
johnny walrus book signing and q a and
thank you to matt walsh if this isn't
live anymore or you are just catching up
with this or listening to the podcast
johnny the walrus is still available to
the end of the week when you buy a daily
wire all access membership so fear not
check it out at dailywire.com johnny
before the end of the weekend good night
to everyone and special shout out to all
of our new members your support helps us
impact culture by creating new
alternatives and helps us keep
delivering great content including books
like johnny the walrus and new shows
like mine the comment section with brett
cooper plus our upcoming dw kids series
movies documentaries podcasts and so
much more to come so thanks again and we
will see you next time
you